right on all right let's jump into this
first story check out this tweet we got
this tweet from Benny Johnson he posted
the video from Project Veritas I suppose
I could have just pulled it up from
Veritas but Benny Johnson had a really
great hashtag attached to it lied
suddenly and we all thought that was
pretty good so shout out to Benny and uh
this is the video I'll play just a
little bit 10 minutes long I'm not gonna
play the whole thing for you but we'll
play a little bit of this so you can see
what happens
you work for Pfizer my question for you
is why is Pfizer want to hide from the
public the fact that they're mutating
the covet viruses I'm literally a liar I
was trying to impress a person on a date
don't touch me well this is not why the
way how are you doing don't tell anybody
who's just working in a company
yeah
you really did please
can you please unlock your door no no
don't let them move